hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einer weiteren
folge minecraft minecraft maut ist dass
minecraft projekt von max und mia max
ist er hier
hey ich bin der hier ob topleute wir
haben heute hier in challenge für euch
vorbereitet und heute wird es mal ein
bisschen es und für luca ich habe letzte
folge mit dem bereits kämpfen müssen
weil luca mir die ganze zeit war samir
ein gefütterter hat er gesagt
noch mehr noch mehr was du stellst
tatsächlich nie wilster unterwelt ich
habe dir vielleicht vielleicht 15 mal
gesagt es ist also wirklich wirklich
krass gewesen wie luca mich letzte folge
fertig gemacht hat aber sogar es ist mir
ganz egal ich will dich nämlich heute
fertig machen
du darfst heute waren immer ist der sage
eiswürfel in dein t-shirt stecken das im
august eine unerwartete die sogar schon
eisel fühlt stehen leute ist es nämlich
heute die weihnachts folge wenn ihr das
seht und aus diesem grund dachte ich mir
machen wir doch mal ein bisschen
weihnachtsstimmung und machte es uns ein
bisschen kalt wie wärs denn buchmesse
und leute hier in der schale sind
eiswürfel drin ihr seht das schon hier
so kleine und immer wenn max was sagt
sie muss ich mir quasi so eine kleine
handvoll davon irgendwie den nacken
stecken und ihr seht schon ich habe
merchandise an außerdem ist der wille
stiftung.de und ich hoffe dass mich
dieser pulli zumindest ein bisschen warm
hält aber wir widmen uns ja erstmal
europa der tunnel ein motto [ __ ] guck
mal da investoren schauen wir dann
inventar ich habe auch verlage wollen
wir noch ganz schnell mal eben durch die
höhle durch reden und vielleicht schaut
wie diamanten kriegen
okay das wäre krass lasst uns mal bitte
vorher die wichtigsten sachen mitnehmen
die wir in unserer base haben so dass
wir hier sonntag die öfen oder so können
wir stehen lassen aber halt die die
länder inhaltlichen die da bleibt er
weiß was meine haben schon alles
rausgeholt dann würde ich sagen du
läufst vor ich glaube die hinterher aber
im moment warten macht jetzt ich finde
es so heiß mit den ganzen tag in der
luca steckt jedoch ein eiswürfel in
pully bastian immer auch diese
behinderten überleitung ich nehme jetzt
hier einfach mal so wie wir sind das
vier als würfel hier in meiner hand und
führte die hinten immer es ist einmal in
paulis alles in meinem beruf machen
husum
ich musste die gerade für sie da draußen
ich warte ich denke hier ein erstes
bisschen challenge ich habe meinen
rücken so angespannt dass das die
eiswürfel hinter meinem rücken sind am
limit ist ein ekelhaftes gefühl was du
sagst mir jetzt nicht das geht nicht du
weißt selbst ganz genau was du das
zufolge mit mir gemacht habe ja aber das
war bei dir so ist das ende aber so
läuft ja ok ab hier runter dubai googles
vorgehen aber du kannst kann ich habe
echt ein geschenk für dich hier in rot
einen mond für dich hoch weil ich weiß
dass tumoren so gern mag es ist
wunderschön von dir danke dir ist
überall war das jedoch mit dem shader
wieder sehr sehr krass aus und hier ist
was jetzt noch gold warte ich nehme das
gold noch eben mit ich würde sagen wir
gehen gleich dann links einfach mal
runter ihr müsst willst du leute wir
wollten heute eigentlich so wohl dass
sie tatsächlich sehr stark nach
diamanten hieraus alter die große see
ist wenn wir hier keine finden ne läuft
gerade mal wieder ein stückchen nach
oben um zu schauen ob wir hier schon
waren weil ich glaube ich bin schon mal
kurz lange urls steht einfach so eine
dumme sind so ist es zu groß
ehrlich ja gigantisch guckst du gerade
meine hose oder was den flachen wird
erst mal wie wir zurück wachst ich habe
dir doch die eiswürfel von vorhin hier
drin damit wir ein bisschen was schaffen
verzeihe ich dir den witz und
ausnahmsweise luca musst du dir jetzt
keiner us wirtschaft
das ist sehr sehr die partie dafür muss
das jetzt machen ich hasse dein leben
alter leute diesmal dem ich hier fünf
als würfel ihr seht schon hier und werde
die jetzt in meinen nacken
ok judith fünf genommen
ich habe vorhin schon vier genau wo die
haben sogar zwei weitere ich sehen der
fällt alles kam gerade aus wie stephen
hawking weil es läuft einfach in meine
unterhosen das ist nicht wahr ausmachen
in husum
es liest mein rücken runter mag es ist
nicht mehr schön
es tut so weh es tut so weh es so dass
es okay ist entspannt du kannst du
einfach nur durch die höhle oder direkt
vor meinen augen mein gott bei mir ist
alles gut ja wirklich alles guter brauch
muss ich ein bisschen abkühlen
ich habe keine schmerzen ist einfach nur
so eine unangenehme kälte aber wenn es
so schlimm ist dann beim brecht erst mal
ab ich breche ich ab
es ist nicht so schlimm ist es halt
einfach nur unangenehm es park habe das
größte höhlensystem aller zeiten könnten
glaube ich ja es ist so riesig jeder
gang führt irgendwie weiter oben
außerdem aber es ist so krank ist es
überall einfach ist irgendwie noch
sonntag
dann kann man hier langlaufen und erst
wieder relativ kurz ich weiß diamanten
sind schön diamanten sind gut wir können
diamanten locker irgendwie gebrauchen
aber wir mittlerweile auch irgendwie ein
stück eisen und sohn
das projekt geht ja immer noch sieben
vor es fließt immer ab und zu den rücken
tat ist die weihnachts folge luca frohe
weihnachten
falls ihr euch wundert dass wir nicht so
in der mega weihnachtsstimmung sind wir
nehmen das ganze schon im voraus aber
damit es irgendwie ein bisschen
weihnachtlich ist halt diese challenge
mit preis auch hier sind mit der kripo
explodiert als einfach noch ein kriegt
ja wir können es ja eigentlich erst mal
geradeaus hochbaum einfach oder ja das
ist halt die weihnachtsfeier deswegen
habe ich gedacht wir vielleicht den
schnee die um mark und luca
einen gang der nicht nach oben führt
luca auf tour
in einem gang der in eine schlucht für
einmal ein tag hast du das ja aber es
war keine absicht versprochen
es war keine absicht ok als bestrafung
würde ich sagen ist die wasabi aber
dafür dass du mich gerade so an
geschrieben hast bist du einfach noch
ein preis dafür hinten rein wirkt als
bestrafung dafür dass du mich runter
geschubst hast ja und das dass du dich
an gemacht hat ist zu kritisieren was
ich getan habe hier als würfel ab in den
nacken drin
hahaha okay wenn ich so bin ist es okay
so ist in ordnung so in ordnung nicht so
bleibt ist in ordnung
[Musik]
ganz kleine zwischen info informiert im
schnitt ich merke einfach nur dass ich
mega dem rumpf in wien wegen nur so ein
paar eiswürfel
darin wollte ich nur ganz kurz sagen das
sind keine schmerzen die ich da
irgendwie fake mäßig versucht
rüberzubringen ich hatte in dem moment
habe ich keine schmerzen es war halt
einfach nur so dass es so mega
unangenehm war diese fünf eiswürfel so
hand groß einfach alle im nacken zu
haben und da muss die ganze zeit so
sitzen und es war so arschkalt und so
deswegen aber weiter geht das natürlich
jetzt die perfekte höhe für diamanten
ist ja egal kommen lassen uns immer nach
oben bauen das ist die weihnachts folge
will gehen jetzt in ein weihnachtsbaum
leute borussia zum hochbau in sachen ich
meine vorsicht du weißt genau was du
machen musst wenn du sowas nochmal macht
ja hey du weißt genau was in der
nächsten folge passiert ist es mir egal
im moment bist du erst mal dran mit
leiden
mann du arschloch ist nein nein nein
nein nein
da kommen sie alle aus geflutscht luca
nein also es ist so kalt
du bist gerade gestorben die hör auf
dich zu beschweren dass es kalt ist du
bist gerade gestorben an
holst du meine sachen ja ich bin hier
leute ich mache ganz kurzen card und max
und ich treffen und seine oberfläche
wieder 2000 jahre später
leute wir sind aus der höhle
rausgegangen mag seine sachen einfach
mit geholt und ist nach oben geschoben
und haben dann da hinten irgendwo in dem
wasser da unten raus dadurch kam auch
der kies deswegen nicht gestorben aber
wir sind jetzt auf jeden fall hier ein
bisschen weiter gelaufen weil wir zu
beginn der ersten folge hinten schon ein
schnäppchen
entdeckt haben und hier werden wir jetzt
unser haus errichten oder wollen wir
hier einfach jetzt mal ein
weihnachtliches gebet sprechen oder
wollen wir machen im detail sortieren
eben weil darin er noch fürs haus
errichten als weihnachtliches gebäck
sprechend habe ich das gefühl das ist
produktiver jetzt in der folge ich finds
auf jeden fall sehr geil hier vor allem
auch mit dem winter und so ein bisschen
aber da hinten geht der winter ja auch
noch weiter und da hinten sind auch noch
die winter bäume deren da brennt gerade
einfachen bau munter hügel da oben ist
auf jeden fall der kunden es wert das
heißt ich würde sagen wie
also team jetzt erstmal unser inventar
kommen ein bisschen runter vor der
krassen folge und in deiner nächsten
folge werden wir dann unser haus bauen
und so ein bisschen besiedeln
ich würde an dieser stelle auch sogar
die folge für heute beenden meine damen
und herren wenn euch das video gefallen
hat die minecraft mord folge will ich
mein gott was das für ein projekt locker
hier dieses projektes minecraft maut
hier findet hier ein smiley eingeblendet
meine damen und herren wir darauf könnte
meinen kanal abonnieren und ihr findet
hier unten ein anderes video
eingeblendet irgendeins verlinke ich
damals bestimmt irgendwie an schauens
wert vielleicht auch nicht die nächste
folge minecraft mord findet ihr morgen
auf max kanals in der beschreibung
verlinkt und schau